dans ma tête c'est pas bon tu es toi
tais toi tais toi et toi qu'une recul
[Musique]
elle où la voiture franchement je pense
l'échec que vous allez être contents ils
seront d'ailleurs pas venez on y va
parce que c'est on va d abord les
palaces on va y aller à pied vous un
rêve pour moi partout l'ex friends
valises pas je bien ça me paraît la
moindre des choses si là-bas j'ai prix
minimum parce que tout sera là bas
j'imagine je provost valises
vas-y vas-y maxime tu seras là bas jean
tu leur donnes rama marque que j'aime
pour les crèmes les soins inquiète pas
et pas n'est ce pas ce que je veux juin
soin visage mais après je vous dirai
comment c'était un mariage et c'est un
room service
ah oui ce soir au cabinet revinois par
contre les chiffres insee un soir je
vais m'asseoir s'énerve a vu son visage
se sera pas de trop pour toi vous faire
alors vous on est déjà arrivé belle
entrée là non c'est quoi à l'entrée la
[Rires]
baby gym loisirs 1er mai c'est une
blague
mais m c est génial moi j'ai envie d
être et ben vas-y
vous êtes invités à s'asseoir ce livre
est toujours s'amuse à la mise à siffler
et noir allaient pouces qui a fait ça
c'est quénard plus aussi c'est que ces
tremplins l'amant qu on a tous voila
c'est non
c'est plein d'autres mais c'est pas
drôle là je préfère encore guény 1
ce sont le monde met sa tombe mais aulas
les copains est bon les jeunes la clé
blague contrairement au sexe plus c'est
court mieux c'est reposez-vous ces
malades ou quoi remonte mois sac à dos
par en dessous
le bas salat stop les îles oui baup là
non c'est bon pantalon sa part oui
petite amie du bon côté évidemment j'y
tiens et moi j'ai mis là que mon dieu
mais si on m'avait dit que deux par deux
dans le top 2 des personnes que je
méprise le but de l'émission trop frais
l'autre à côté de toi c'est quand même
quelque chose si tu as froid tu n'y en a
même pas y'a pas de soucis il n'y a pas
de télé rien du coup la limite à
raconter mon histoire
parle-moi honoré par le peintre qui
m'intéresse pas de [ __ ] cas cumulés
tous les cauchemars
c'est 21 spaf à tous attention pas
vraiment je te préviens je crois que
l'on est rendu même ça ça pourrait
m'intéresser à aa
je vais te raconter nos nuits
racontez-nous votre nous parce que je
reconnais qu'il ya un truc qui me avec
toi et qu'en tu parles je m'endors si je
m'endors vraiment demain l'horreur c'est
que j'aimerais bien commencé mais non
c'est au réveil te regardais jamais
oublier ferait partie je me lève tôt
mois lobito l'ong finlandaise je vais
pas ce que c'est qu'un boycott
[Musique]
vous l'avez entendu il il m'a traité et
il était tranquillement dans l'igloo
mais sauf qu en laponie
on tombe bien vous réveiller c'est pas
pour un room service c'est souvent des
loups les loups rodés regardez ces
assassins n'a pu être très dangereux
mais je sais ça fait une séquence du
rôle des gt gt pas loin arrêt alors oui
c'est pas loin et il est donc vous avez
sur ce qu'elle avait dit vous vous êtes
moi quand je suis pas plus fort calhoun
moi non vous n'êtes pas mais moi oui
vraiment un loup a fait une bien fois
j'étais pas loin
biff ces bons sont plus regardés
[Musique]
gilles quoi attend quand on dit
maintenant
là c'est quoi ces des chiens chiens il
ya des chiens sauvages ici tafer ou fnac
alors parle en finlande bah oui bien sûr
c'est à dire que si nous bouffons cbre
et s'attaqueront à moi j'étais d'avis en
faisant d'été vieux est grave c'est vrai
elle attend ça déconne et la ville
d'irak et renifle tentant et gratte là
ils sont plusieurs en plus mais ça n'est
pas du tout ça commence à faire flipper
tu as raison chic de tout temps mais
c'est pourquoi qu'ils achetaient juin
c'était chiant
le prix
qu'est ce que ça peu plus tôt à ça bon
je tourne autour des trucs là mais ça me
pue ça me fait pitié n'importe quoi
tourner autour du truc mesure c'est
vraiment des cons et hors dia google
mais habana ce palace pas là se
retrouvent anigo dégueulasse me tombe
sur la gueule avec des chiens errants au
tour mathieu j'espère que c'est que des
chiens je te crois mer et en matière
d'accueil et toi tais toi et toi aucune
recul paraît il s'est barré il s'est
barré bouge pas et s'est barré avec a
plus de police à hilla aussi peur que
nous partons peut-être suis-je et
mathieu bravo à quoi je découvre que ces
terres ont pensé que c'étaient des
chiens errants
c'est vrai dans une île où des loups
tout tu crois que j'aurais été là rien
faire quoi vous auriez fait quoi
tu sais pas mais en tous les cas le
faisait avec l'été des loups toi non
mais c'est vrai que ça fait très peur
parce que on a l'impression que
quelqu'un va entrer sagrada gratter ils
ont vraiment pas changé après y avoir et
soeurs à côté vous avez débat n'était
pas loin je connais très bien les loups
messager dont j'ai dansé désagréable
parce qu'encore par exemple parfois et
les chiens errants est de ne pas dinh ba
oui mais je vous le dis en tout cas
bravo à vous franchement pour votre
courage on peut elle peut les applaudir
ok
[Musique]